This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. There are currently more than 31,000 post offices in the United States. There are grand old ones that take up entire city blocks, and there are smaller, humblet ones hiding away in the backs of general stores and towns across rural America. But this one in Arizona may be the most rural post office in the Continental US. The Sioux Pie Post Office is located at the bottom of the Grand Canyon. That's Vivian Campbell. My name is Vivian Campbell, and I am the Postmaster of Peach Brings Arizona. Vivian works closely with the Sioux Pie Post Office,
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。目前美国有超过31,000个邮局。有占据整个街区的宏伟老建筑，也有隐藏在乡村杂货店后方、朴实无华的小邮局。但亚利桑那州的这个邮局可能是美国本土最偏远的邮局。苏派邮局位于大峡谷底部。那是薇薇安·坎贝尔。我叫薇薇安·坎贝尔，我是亚利桑那州桃泉的邮政局长。薇薇安与苏派邮局密切合作，
and she says there are only a few ways to get mail to the bottom of the Grand Canyon. You either have to hike down there, ride a mule, or ride a horse. And so every day, Rainer Shine, mail gets packed on 10 mules to make a 2.5 hour trip into the canyon. The post office is there to serve the people who live on the Avasupai reservation. Avasupai meaning blue-green water people, named for the waterfall at the bottom of the canyon. The falls are just magnificent. The water is so blue, it's not even indescribable. The Avasupai receive a lot of food supplies, but otherwise their mail is pretty standard fare. They get packages from Amazon, they get first-class mail, they get bills just like you and me.
她说将邮件送到大峡谷底部的方法屈指可数。你必须徒步下去，或者骑骡子，或者骑马。所以每天，无论风雨，邮件都会装在10头骡子上，进行2.5小时的峡谷之旅。这个邮局是为了服务居住在哈瓦苏派保留地的人们。哈瓦苏派意为“蓝绿水之民”，得名于峡谷底部的瀑布。瀑布非常壮观。水是那么蓝，简直无法形容。哈瓦苏派人收到很多食品补给，但除此之外，他们的邮件和普通人没什么两样。他们收到亚马逊的包裹，收到一等邮件，收到账单，就像你我一样。
They could just from Amazon, they get first class mail, they get bills just like you and me. The Supa Post Office was established in 1896, and its existence speaks to the links that the US Post Office has gone to connect people with each other and to unite us as a country. Ever since the service was founded in the late 1700s. I was sitting on my back porch in Wyoming one night, you know, there's the sun, sank
他们收到亚马逊的包裹，收到一等邮件，收到账单，就像你我一样。苏派邮局成立于1896年，它的存在证明了美国邮政为连接人们、团结国家所付出的努力。自该服务在18世纪末成立以来。有一天晚上，我坐在怀俄明州的后廊上，你知道，太阳落在了金色的西部，我突然从椅子上跳起来，对我丈夫尖叫道：邮局创造了美国。那是作家兼历史学家温妮弗雷德·加拉格尔，她根据这一发现写了一本书，书名非常贴切：《邮局如何创造了美国：一部历史》。加拉格尔认为，邮局不仅创造了一种从加州奥克兰向大峡谷寄信的高效且廉价的方式。这项服务旨在将一群分散的城镇和人民团结在一面旗帜下。
in the Golden West, and I just jumped up out of the chair and then shrieked at my husband, the post office created America. That is author and historian Winiford Gallagher, and she wrote a book based on this revelation called, appropriately. How the post office created America, a history. Gallagher argues that the Post Office didn't just create an efficient and inexpensive way to send a letter from Oakland, California, into the Grand Canyon. The service was designed to unite a bunch of disparate towns and people under one flag.
通过这样做，邮局实际上创造了美利坚合众国。几千年来，政府一直有跨距离发送信息的方式。但在历史的大部分时间里，邮件仅限于政府、军队以及最终那些负担得起这项服务的富人之间的通信。这就是早期殖民地美国邮政系统的样子。英国皇室建立了皇家邮政，主要用于将信息从英国传送到美国。一旦邮件从英国到达美国，就会由一个叫“邮差”的人分发，正如其名，他是一个骑马的人。当时没有适合轮式车辆行驶的道路。
And in doing so, the Post Office actually created the United States of America. For thousands of years, governments have had ways of sending information across distances. But for most of history, the mail was limited to correspondence between governments, militaries, and eventually wealthy people who could afford to pay for such a service. And that's what the postal system of early colonized America was like. The crown's post was put in place by the English monarchy and was mostly used to get messages from England to America. Once the mail landed from England into America, it would be circulated by a fellow called a postwriter who just like he sounds, he was a man on a horse. There were no roads suitable for a wheeled vehicle.
当时，散布在从新罕布什尔州到佐治亚州东海岸的殖民地对彼此沟通并不感兴趣。这些殖民地就像非常易怒、好争辩的兄弟姐妹。他们之间几乎没有什么往来。他们都在争夺英国母亲的关注。但当一个名叫本杰明·富兰克林的进取心强的人成为皇家邮政局长时，这一切开始改变。
At the time, the colonies which dotted the eastern coast from New Hampshire down to Georgia weren't that interested in communicating with each other. The colonies were very fractious, disputacious siblings. They had very little to do with each other. They were acclimoring for the attention of Mother England. But all of this started to change when an enterprising fellow named Benjamin Franklin
作为邮政局长，富兰克林负责确保邮件在殖民地送达正确地点。他决心改善这个简陋的系统。他实际上走访了每一个殖民地。那是在这还是件非常麻烦的事情的时候。他建立了里程邮资，这样你就可以根据信件的距离收费，
became postmaster for the crown. As postmaster, Franklin was in charge in making sure male and the colony has got to its proper location. And he was determined to improve the barebone system. He actually visited every colony. This is back when it was a real pain in the neck. He established myelposts so you could charge fairleaf for the distance of the letter was
而不是仅仅估算。但随着富兰克林努力改善皇家系统，他开始以不同的眼光看待这些殖民地。我相信，走访并思考这13个殖民地的过程，不仅是断开的，而且是链条中的环节。我认为这让他开始思考他们作为一个民族团结起来的方式。1754年，在纽约奥尔巴尼的一次殖民地代表会议上，富兰克林提出了一个计划，
going instead of just estimating it. But as Franklin worked to improve the crown system, he began to see the colonies differently. I believe that the process of going around and thinking about these 13 colonies as not just disconnected, but links in a chain. I think this started him thinking about ways that they could come together as a people. In 1754, at a meeting of colonial representatives in Albany, New York, Franklin proposed a plan
用于团结殖民地。他实际上勾勒出了一个联邦政府，殖民地可以选举自己的代表，而不是由皇室任命。英国并不欣赏富兰克林的这些想法，殖民者也还没准备好。但20年后，关于美国自治的观念正在传播。殖民地的革命者需要一种方式来交流日益增长的独立运动，他们知道不能使用皇家邮政。
for you nutting the colonies. He actually kind of sketched out a federal government where the colonies would elect their own representatives as opposed to having them appointed by the Crown. England didn't appreciate Franklin's ideas, and colonists weren't quite ready for them either. But 20 years later, notions about American self-governance were spreading. Revolutionaries in the colonies needed a way to communicate about the growing movement for independence, and they knew they couldn't use the crown's post.
因为如果他们使用皇家系统，他们的信件会被拦截，他们会被逮捕。1774年，这些美国革命者创建了自己的通信系统，称为“宪政邮政”。在他们进行革命或拥有政府体系之前，在《独立宣言》和宪法之前，美国人就有了邮政。地下的宪政邮政对于煽动革命至关重要，这使美国获得了脱离英国的独立，但它仍然是一个非常有限的系统。全国只有不到一百个邮局，而且该系统服务的范围并不广。
Because if they used the crown system, their letters would be intercepted and they'd be arrested. In 1774, these American revolutionaries created their own system to communicate, called the Constitutional Post. Before they fought the Revolution or had a system of government, before the Declaration of Independence and the Constitution, Americans had the Post. The underground constitutional post was crucial in fomenting the revolution, which gave America independence from England, but it was still a very limited system. There were fewer than a hundred post offices in the entire country, and the system didn't serve that many people.
它基本上是政治精英们相互交流的工具。开国元勋们想要一个更好的邮政系统，一个能服务于他们新生国家的所有人民，并帮助他们团结在一面旗帜下的系统。这些人已经越过阿巴拉契亚山脉，进入了俄亥俄州和肯塔基州的蛮荒西部。开国元勋本杰明·拉什特别相信邮局将在新民主国家中发挥关键作用。他痴迷于邮局应该向每个美国人分发报纸的想法。如果人民没有文化，没有最新的政治信息，就不可能拥有受过教育的选民。但这绝非易事。他们需要道路基础设施和劳动力。
It was basically a tool for political elites to communicate with each other. The founders wanted a better post, one that would serve all people in their infant nation, and help them stay united under one flag. These people who were already spreading over the Appalachians into the Wild West of Ohio and Kentucky. Founding father Benjamin Rush especially believed that the post office would play a crucial role in the new democracy. He was obsessed with the idea that the post office should circulate newspapers to every American. You couldn't have an educated electorate if the people weren't literate and they didn't have up-to-date political information. But this would be no small undertaking. They need an infrastructure of roads and a workforce.
这个政府几乎没有钱。它在勉强维持。然而他说，我们将拥有这个非常、非常雄心勃勃的邮政系统，比欧洲的任何系统都要雄心勃勃。这真的很令人震惊。1792年，国会通过了《邮政法》。根据该法案，建立了新的邮政路线。审查或窃取邮件成为可惩罚的罪行，所有报纸都可以以同样的低费率邮寄，以促进信息的传播。
This government had very little money. It was running on fumes. And yet he says we're going to have this very, very ambitious postal system, much more ambitious than anything in Europe. It's really kind of astounding. In 1792, Congress passed the Post Office Act. Under the Act, new postal routes were established. Sensoring or stealing mail became a punishable offense, and all newspapers could be mailed at the same low rate to promote the spread of information.
这引发了各种政治观点的报纸的大爆发。邮局是人们获取信息的主要方式，有时甚至是唯一方式。它就是媒体。我们当时是新闻迷。开国元勋们确保我们将拥有一个不受审查、活跃、充满争议的政治文化，因为他们希望人民接触到各种观点，
It set off a huge explosion of newspapers from all sorts of political viewpoints. The Post Office was the main way, sometimes the only way people got information. It was the media. We were news junkies back then. The founders ensured that we would have an uncensored, lively, contentious political culture because they wanted the people to be exposed to all kinds of views
并进行辩论，然后投票。从一开始，我们就一直在争论、传播流言蜚语和信息，并非所有信息都是真实的。在某种程度上，你知道，你可以采取一种态度，他们创造了一个科学怪人，但事实上，这是有意为之的。大约在同一时间，18世纪末，驿站马车成为一种更流行的旅行方式，也是比骑马送信更好的方式。邮局开始与私人驿站马车公司签订合同来运送邮件，并且
and argue it out and then vote. We've been arguing and gossiping and spreading information, not all of it true since the very beginning. In a way, you know, you could take the attitude of they sort of created a Frankenstein, but in fact, it was by design. Around the same time in the late 1700s, the stage coach was becoming a more popular way to travel and a better way to carry mail than just packing up a rider on a horse. The post office started to contract with private stage coach companies to carry mail, and
这些公司与城市和城镇合作修建道路。通过这种方式，邮政帮助开辟了国家早期的交通基础设施，连接了分散的社区。当一群人在一个新的地方定居时，居民会向政府请愿设立邮局，这给了他们一个地址和地图上的位置。然后那个城镇就会与路上的另一个城镇连接起来。你开始拥有这种网络。它不仅通过道路发展了我们的物理景观，还发展了社会景观，这样你就可以开始谈论这个巨大的国家，就像有一些地点一样。1831年，当法国外交官兼作家亚历克西斯·德·托克维尔游历美国时，他
these companies worked with cities and towns to build roads. In this way, the post helped carve out the early transportation infrastructure of the country, connecting disparate communities. When a group of people settled in a new place, the residents would petition the government for a post office, which gave them the address in a place on the map. And then that town would be connected to another town down the road. You started to have this kind of network. It's developed not just our physical landscape with roads, but a social landscape so that you could start to talk about this huge country with like some locations. In 1831, when the French diplomat and writer Alexis de Tocqueville toured America, he was
对我们的邮政系统感到惊讶。他坐着驿站马车穿过密歇根内陆的某个地方，看到人们从那种简陋的小屋里出来，渴望得到报纸，并且能够谈论不仅是美国政治，还有欧洲正在发生的事情？他惊呆了。此时，美国的邮件主要是关于发送和接收报纸。人们并不真正寄信，因为他们负担不起。他们保持高昂的信件邮资，并利用信件的收入来支付
amazed by our postal system. He's riding in a stage coach through some place in the Michigan Outback, and he sees people coming out of these kind of crude huts, you know, cabins, desperate to get the newspapers and able to talk about not just American politics, but what's going on in Europe? He's flabbergasted. At this point, the mail in the US was mostly about sending and receiving newspapers. People didn't really send letters because they couldn't afford to. They kept the rates for letters high and they used that revenue from letters to pay for
向各地所有美国人投递报纸的费用。大多数人一年收到的信件不到一封。你会收到一封信说，你知道，爸爸去世了，或者你会收到像拉蒂莎阿姨的遗嘱。而且与今天不同，今天寄信人支付邮费，当时收件人必须付费。你去邮局，排队看看是否有你的邮件，如果你想要，就付钱。这造成了大量无人认领的邮件积压，因为很多人，很多人不想付钱。在19世纪40年代和50年代，国家人口随着新移民的涌入而爆炸式增长，所有这些新移民
the delivery of newspapers to all Americans everywhere. Most people got like fewer than one letter a year. You get a letter saying, you know, Pa has died or you'd get like Aunt Latisha's will. And unlike today, with a person sending a letter covers the cost of postage, back then, the recipient had to pay. You go to the post office, you'd stand in line and see if you had mail, and then pay for it if you wanted it. It created this fantastic backlog of unclaimed mail because so many people, so many people didn't want to pay. In the 1840s and 50s, the population of the country exploded with new immigrants, and all these new people
都想要一种更便宜的交流方式。廉价邮资运动开始形成。这场运动希望人们能够以一个低廉的价格向美国任何地方寄信，使用一种新工具。预付邮资的邮票。他们认为邮件量会增加到足以弥补收入的程度，他们是对的，因为邮件量
wanted a less expensive way to communicate. A movement for cheap postage started to form. This movement wanted people to be able to send letters anywhere in the US for one low price, using a new tool. The prepaid postage stamp. They argued that the volume of the mail would increase to a degree that would make up for the revenue, and they were correct, because the volume of the mail
在廉价邮资之后确实猛增。邮票允许普通人寄信。人们寄出的信件足以填满成千上万部肯·伯恩斯的纪录片。那是维多利亚时代，写信成为了一种艺术形式。甚至还有关于如何润色写信风格的书籍。用头衔称呼你的通信者，而不是名字。亲爱的丈夫，挚爱的兄弟，最亲爱的朋友，等等。无论你们有多亲密，
really went gangbusters after cheap postage. The postage stamp allowed regular people to send letters. People sent enough letters to fill thousands of Ken Burns documentaries. It was the Victorian era, and letter writing became an art form. There were even books with advice on how to refine your letter writing style. Address your correspondent by his or her title, not the first name. Dear husband, beloved brother, dearest friend, on its sur. No matter how close you are,
不要用他的名字称呼他。以“我提笔写信”开始你的信。请原谅糟糕的纸张、粗糙的笔、不优雅的语言。女性尤其成为了狂热的写信者。女性甚至开始在脖子上戴着小挂坠盒，里面装着邮票。随着越来越多的女性使用邮局，这个地方本身也开始改变。邮局历史上经常设在酒馆的后面。它们是男性的社交空间。你知道，邮局里有妓女在兜售她们的商品，还有扒手，
don't address him by his first name. Begin your letter with, I take pen in hand. Please pardon the poor paper, the scratchy pen, the ungraceful language. Women especially became avid letter writers. Women actually started wearing little rockets around their necks with their stamps inside. With more women using the post office, the place itself began to change. Post offices historically had been often in the backs of taverns. They were men's social spaces. You know, there were prostitutes at the post office supplying their wares and pickpock,
著名的扒手。当女性开始寄信时，邮局增加了专门的女士窗口，这样女士们就可以在不接触这些不雅元素的情况下领取信件。慢慢地，邮局转型为更专业的空间。到1860年，美国约有28,000个邮局。人们互相寄送成千上万封信件和新发明的贺卡。但他们也像开国元勋们预想的那样，利用邮政来传播政治信息。例如，废奴主义者利用邮件传播关于结束
famously pickpockets. When women started sending letters, post offices added special ladies windows so that ladies could pick up their letters without coming into contact with these unsimly elements. Slowly, post offices transitioned into more professional spaces. By 1860, there were some 28,000 post offices in the US. People were sending thousands of letters and newly invented greeting cards to each other. But they were also using the post just like the founders intended to disseminate political information. Abolitionists, for example, were using the mail to spread ideas about ending
奴隶制的思想。在19世纪60年代，当内战因其中一些思想而爆发时，美国邮局一度分裂。南北之间不再寄送邮件。内战给美国的邮政系统带来了另一个重大变化：送货上门。俄亥俄州的一名邮政员工，名叫约瑟夫·布里格斯，在战争期间感到非常心碎，因为那些急于得到远方士兵消息的人们不得不站在邮局排长队。通常这些人会收到亲人阵亡的消息。
slavery. In the 1860s, when the Civil War was being fought over some of those very ideas, the American Post Office would bifurcate for a time. No male would be sent between North and South. In the Civil War brought another big change in America's postal system, home delivery. Postal employee in Ohio, named Joseph Briggs, found it heartbreaking during the war because people desperate for news of their soldiers away would have to stand in long lines at the post office. Often these people would be receiving news of a level one staff.
公共场合出现了极其悲痛的场景。他们甚至没有隐私。他觉得这太令人心碎了，于是他开展了这个将邮件送到人们手中的试点项目。送货上门流行起来，到19世纪60年代中期，许多城市都提供了这项服务。大约30年后，居住在农村地区的人们也将获得送货上门服务。但是，当美国东部的人们进入写信热潮时，加州的新定居者感到被孤立了。在西海岸接收邮件很困难。所以邮件可以通过火车运到密苏里州，但随后必须由驿站马车运送
And there were just scenes of terrible terrible grief in public. They didn't even have a privacy. And he found it so heartbreaking that he ran this pilot program of bringing people to mail. Home delivery caught on, and by the mid-1860s, many cities were offering it. About 30 years later, people living in rural areas would also get home delivery. But while people in the Eastern United States entered a letter writing boom, new settlers in California felt isolated. It was hard to receive mail on the West Coast. So the mail could go by train to Missouri, but then it had to be hauled by stage coaches
穿过非常糟糕的环境。另一个选择是把信件通过船只绕过南美洲尖端进行13,000英里、为期六个月的旅行。加州人在淘金热时代及随后的几年里变得更加强大，他们对拥有这种糟糕的邮政服务感到愤怒，并要求拥有一个能在可预测的时间出发和到达的可靠驿站马车邮件服务。最终他们得到了他们想要的。到1857年，邮局有了一条从东到西相当可靠的路线。这花了25天，比以前好多了，
through really terrible conditions. The other option would be to send a letter on a 13,000-mile six-month trip around the tip of South America by boat. Californians, as they became more powerful by the Golden Rush era and the succeeding years, became outraged by the fact that they had this lousy postal service and they demanded to have a reliable stagecoach male that would depart and arrive on predictable times. Eventually they got what they wanted. By 1857, the post office had a fairly reliable root from East to West. It took 25 days, which was better than it had been,
但仍然不够好。一群由威廉·拉塞尔领导的商人认为他们可以做得比美国邮政更好。拉塞尔认为他的小创业公司可以在短短10天内将邮件从密苏里州的圣约瑟夫送到加州的萨克拉门托。事实上，他做到了。人们认为他做不到。
but it was still not great. A group of businessmen led by a guy named William Russell thought that they could do better than the US post. Russell thought his little startup company could get the mail from St. Joseph, Missouri to Sacramento, California in just 10 days. He, in fact, he did it. People didn't think he'd be able to do it.
拉塞尔的竞争服务被称为“小马快递”。骑马的人会全速奔跑约10或15英里，到达接力站，在那里他们会换上一匹休息好的马。这种更换应该只需要两分钟。马匹携带的重量不得超过165磅，包括骑手。如果一匹精疲力竭的马在路上倒下，骑手必须带着他的邮件袋徒步跑到下一个地点。这是一项非常昂贵的努力，而且持续时间不长，大约一年半，这没关系，因为到1861年，横贯大陆的电报将到达加州，铁路服务也将紧随其后。
Russell's competing service was called the Pony Express. Riders on horseback would race at full speed for about 10 or 15 miles to relay stations where they would trade out for a rusted horse. This change was supposed to take only two minutes. Horses were to carry no more than 165 pounds, including the rider. If an exhausted horse collapsed on the trail, the rider was to run on foot to the next location with his bag of mail. It was a very expensive endeavor and it didn't last long, about a year and a half, which was okay because by 1861, the transcontinental telegraph would reach California, and rail service would soon follow.
横贯大陆的电报将到达加州，铁路服务也将紧随其后。火车最终将把邮件送到美国各地，不仅是运送，而且成为移动的邮局。事实上，来自邮局的补贴允许铁路系统在全国范围内扩张。火车无法仅靠客运票价维持运营。他们从邮局获得的资金对于帮助他们扩大服务至关重要。几年前，这些邮政补贴对驿站马车也做了同样的事情，第一次世界大战后，邮政将再次为航空业这样做。
Transcontinental telegraph would reach California, and rail service would soon follow. Trains would eventually deliver mail all over the US and not just deliver it, but become moving post offices. In fact, subsidies from the post office allowed the rail system to expand throughout the country. Trains couldn't afford to run on passenger fare alone. The money they got from the post office was crucial in helping them expand service. Years earlier, these postal subsidies had done the same thing for stage coaches, and after World War I, the post would do this again for aviation.
在邮局向该行业投入资金之前，飞机并不是一种可行的交通方式。航空业直到20世纪40年代才能够通过客运服务实现自给自足。该行业通过为邮局运送邮件而生存和扩张。事实上，在查尔斯·林德伯格进行历史性的横跨大西洋不着陆飞行之前，他还有另一份工作。查尔斯·林德伯格是一名夜间飞行员，你知道，他运送邮件。如果邮局真的创造了美国，而且我认为温妮弗雷德·加拉格尔提出了一个很好的理由证明它确实做到了，那么它现在扮演着更辅助的角色。
Plains were not a viable form of transportation until the post office poured money into the industry. The aviation industry wasn't able to pay for itself with passenger service until well into the 1940s. The industry survived and expanded by carrying mail for the post office. In fact, before Charles Lindbergh made his historic nonstop flight across the Atlantic, he had another job. Charles Lindbergh was a night pilot, you know, he carried the mail. If the post office truly created America, and I think Winiford Gallagher makes a pretty good case that it did, it's now playing a more supporting role.
在过去的40年左右，国会大幅削减了服务，如果你注意到邮局排队时间变长，邮件接收延迟，这就是原因。在我看来，没有人应该对邮局生气。他们应该对国会生气。国会阻止了邮局现代化和高效运营，并悲剧性地走向数字化，这本应在80年代就完成。加拉格尔认为邮局错失了促进电子邮件和其他数字通信的机会，但她认为美国邮政服务可能也没有濒临死亡。保守派谈论将整个业务私有化，但目前，加拉格尔怀疑
In the last 40 years or so, Congress has cut back considerably on services, and if you've noticed longer lines of the post office and delays in receiving your mail, that's why. In my opinion, no one should be mad at the post office. They should be mad at Congress. Congress has prevented the post office from modernizing and running itself efficiently and tragically going digital, which it should have done back in the 80s. Galliore believes the post office missed an opportunity to facilitate email and other digital communication, but she argues the US Postal Service probably isn't on the brink of death either. Conservatives talk about privatizing the whole operation, but right now, Gallagher doubts
这是可能的。实际上，私人竞争对手，无论是联邦快递还是UPS，都没有能力处理美国邮件的业务量。如果他们尝试，他们肯定会面临破产的风险。邮局拥有无与伦比的投递基础设施，并雇佣了庞大的劳动力，我们仍然需要他们提供的服务，因为与联邦快递和UPS不同，美国邮局不能根据利润选择投递地点。法律规定它必须为全国每个社区提供取件和投递服务，即使该社区位于大峡谷底部。
that this is possible. Actually, the private competitors, neither FedEx or UPS, is equipped to handle the volume of American mail. They would certainly risk bankruptcy if they tried. The Post Office has an unparalleled delivery infrastructure and employs an enormous workforce, and we still need the service they provide because unlike FedEx and UPS, the US Post Office cannot pick and choose where they deliver based on profit. It is obliged by law to provide pick-ups and deliveries to every community in the country, even if that community is located in the bottom of the Grand Canyon.
《99%隐形》本周由凯蒂·明格尔制作，德莱尼·霍尔、谢丽·福塞夫、艾弗里·特鲁夫勒门特、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、萨姆·格林斯潘和我罗曼·马尔斯参与。库尔特·斯特德是我们的数字总监，塔伦·马扎负责办公室和我们所有人，肖恩·里亚尔创作了所有音乐。米歇尔·洛弗勒对邮局了解很多。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在广播街制作。在美丽的加州奥克兰市中心。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PI_org。我们在Instagram和Tumblr上也有账号。但如果你想读一个关于英国海军建造一艘由冰和木浆制成的永不沉没的船的故事，而不是
99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Katie Mingle with Delaney Hall, Sheree Fusef, Avery Trufflement, Emmett Fitzgerald, Sam Greenspan, and me Roman Mars. Kurtstead is our digital director, Taren Mazza, takes care of the office, and us all, Sean Rial composed all the music. And Michelle Loeffler knows a lot about the post office. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row. In beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI Ork. We're on Instagram and Tumblr too. But if you want to read a story about the British Navy building an unsinkable ship made of ice and wood pulp instead
钢，那是真实的事情。你必须去99pi.org。Radio-tempio。来自PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
of steel, that's a real thing. You have to go to 99pi.org. Radio-tempio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
钢铁，那是真实存在的东西。你必须去99pi.org。Radio-tempio。来自PRX。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。